you j'espère que vous allez bien
j'espère que vos proches vont bien c'est
une période très difficile pour tout le
monde 5,3 de voir comment notre
perception du virus a changé en quelques
mots la perception que j'avais du virus
dans ma dernière vidéo et celle que j'ai
là maintenant ça n'a rien à voir donc à
l'encontre cette vidéo je voulais
vraiment vous envoyer toutes mes ondes
positives et voilà j'espère encore une
fois sincèrement que tout va bien
de votre côté petite précision erratum
dans ma dernière vidéo
j'ai parlé au début de 80% des gens qui
étaient à symptomatique c'est une erreur
c'est dé parler des gens qui ont des
symptômes bénins
youtube ne permet pas de corriger la
vidéo en tant que tel donc j'ai épinglé
un commentaire je l'échangé la
description
mais voilà c'est important de vous le
dire gamme en vidéo il ya donc depuis
quelques jours maintenant un confinement
c'est à dire que voilà mais tous chez
nous on doit rester chez nous c'est
important de rester chez soi il ya
encore beaucoup de monde dehors le fait
de rester chez soi permet de limiter la
propagation du virus
donc c'est important qu'on le fasse mais
c'est pas facile de travail chez soi et
je le sais bien parce que c'est un truc
que je fais depuis genre cinq ans et
cinq ans que je me prépare en fait pour
ce moment et donc je me suis dit que ça
pourrait être intéressant que je vous
donne mes meilleurs conseils
ce que j'ai appris dans ces cinq
dernières années parce qu'en fait c'est
vraiment pas facile je me souviens qu'au
tout début j'essayais d'aller dans des
cafés etc pour parce que j'arrivais pas
travailler de chez moi est vraiment ça a
mis des mois voire des années à ce que
j'apprivoise le travail de la maison et
donc je dis ça pourrait être intéressant
que voilà je vous transmettre tout ce
que je fais là dessus une des choses les
plus importantes c'est que vous allez
peut-être remarqué que travailler de
chez soi fait que le temps passe
différemment les journées je parais
passe plus vite
et en même temps plus lentement c'est
bien c'est bizarre à expliquer mais vous
le devez le sentir tout ça que c'est
important d'avoir vraiment un cap dans
la journée parce que si on n'a pas de
cap ba on divague et caetera et bah
quand c'est chez soi c'est très
dangereux
donc pour ça il ya un truc très simple
c'est que il faut faire ça à tout doux
donc les choses à faire dans sa journée
la veille la veille au soir avant de se
coucher
je pense que je referai d'autres vidéos
sur la productivité parce que c'est
vraiment un sujet qui me passionne
donc j'en reparlerai mais c'est vraiment
un truc capital de faire ça tout doux la
veille et voire même on en reparlera
j'imagine sur cette chaîne mais en début
de semaine avant de commencer la semaine
de faire ça une tout doute semaine c'est
bien aussi le fait de faire ça tout doux
la veille aussi ça aide parce que si
vous rendez compte que par exemple on
vous cale plein de visioconférence à ce
que ben on les a plus en entreprise ces
requérants d'entreprise on peut très
facilement dit ray cyrus on peut voir
deux secondes je te parle d'un truc etc
si vous voyez que votre agenda se
remplit de choses comme ça
c'est aussi le moment de dire non parce
que vous avez fait votre tout doux la
veille et que vous savez que vous avez
besoin de ce temps là pour faire autre
chose et pour livrer d'autres trucs
l'autre élément qui va vous aider dans
le fait de travailler de chez soi c'est
de s'habiller comme si vous alliez au
taf
ou comme si vous alliez à l'école où
j'avoue je pense plus aux gens qui
travaillent mais c'est pareil si vous
êtes étudiant globalement sur tous les
conseils que je donne et le fait de
s'habiller comme si tu allais au travail
sarata de mettre dans un délire mindset
yamaha
ça te mettre dans un état d'esprit de
travail tout simplement je suis pas la
maison je suis pas là pour glander je
reste pas en pyjama au fond de mon lit
voilà tout ce genre de choses en fait en
vous mettant dans des conditions
physiques similaires vous allez vous
mettre dans des conditions mentales
similaires et donc ça implique aussi de
prendre un petit déjeuner de faire tout
comme si vous alliez au travail quoi
élément important la séparation de
l'espace j'ai vécu pendant deux ans dans
un 13 mètres carrés
je sais que ça peut être très difficile
l'idée c'est de ne pas travailler au
même endroit où vous regardez la télé au
même endroit où vous dormez en gros
avoir un environnement dédié au travail
ça peut être vraiment sur un coin de la
cuisine ça peut être je sais pas mais
l'idée c'est vraiment d'essayer d'être
assis dans une position la plus
confortable possible avec vos moyens
je sais que c'est pas facile encore une
fois je suis passée par là mais c'est
très important de séparer l'espace de
travail
du reste pour la même raison qu'avec le
fait de s'habiller en fait pour aller au
travail
en séparant physiquement les espaces
vous séparez mentalement
l'état d'esprit dans lequel vous êtes en
fonction de là où vous êtes dans la
maison ou dans l'appartement où dans la
chambre de bonne tnt c'est on a vu
l'aspiration de l'espace et notre
séparation importante c'est celle du
temps quand on travaille de chez soi il
ya un piège qui est qu'on peut finir en
fait part travailler trop faire des
horaires qui n'ont aucun sens ça c'est
mauvais pour plusieurs raisons ses
mauvais parce que ça peut vous décaler
ses mauvais parce que bas à force de
trop travailler et pas prendre du temps
pour vous vu qu'on part potentiellement
sur de longues périodes de confinement
pas ça fait que votre travail va plus
être un plaisir si ça l'est déjà pas ça
va être encore pire donc prenez du temps
pour vous et pour ça c'est très simple
genre séparer le temps c'est à dire que
vous dites voilà je travaille jusqu'à
telle heure où je fais une pause jusqu'à
telle heure après cette heure là paf je
change d'activité j'ai hyper important
bien sûr
que le coupable était après évidemment
si à un moment vous avez trop de taf à
faire et que vous êtes plus heureux en
faisant staff la queue en regardant une
série en train de stressé parce que vous
n'êtes pas finie staff
enfin je veux dire adaptez vous aussi
c'est un autre conseil très important
que je pense que c'est peut-être même le
plus important dans ce cas pour moi dans
la manière avec laquelle j'ai vécu le
fait travailler à la maison c'est ne
soyez pas trop dur avec vous même très
facile de se laisser distraire quand on
est chez soi et de passer une heure
regarder je sais pas quoi et un suis
peut-être hyper mal de se dire je suis
malade et donc du coup ses six enfants
dans un cercle presque vicieux parce
qu'on est moins bon tu as for an parce
qu'on culpabilise de ce qu'on vient de
faire enfin bref ne soyez pas trop dur
avec vous même je me souviens que quand
je me suis mis à travailler de chez moi
par rapport à quand je travaillais en
entreprise j'étais plus dur avec moi
même lorsque j'étais chez moi que
lorsque j'étais d'entreprise et si vous
êtes dur avec vous même quand vous êtes
chez vous bah c'est la merde parce que
vous êtes censée être celle où tout le
temps donc ça que vous allez créer un
environnement négatif autour de vous
tout le temps donc c'est très très
important ce point c'est ok de faire des
pauses c'est ok de de se laisser aller à
un moment c'est tout ça c'est ok
maintenant autre point important c'est
sur quoi vont vous juger les autres
parce que moi c'est particulier je
travaille chez moi mais je travaille à
mon conte qui a beaucoup d'entre vous
grande majorité je pense qu'ils
travaillent avec d'autres gens qui
travaillent au sein d'entreprises etc
et quand je les déconseille de gens qui
sont ces cas de figure là et quand je
pars avec des gens qui sont dans ce cas
de figure là en gros ce qui ressort
c'est qu'on va vous juger sur ce que
vous en voyez ce que vous les sur vos
mails sur les livrables
c'est à dire si vous devez envoyer tel
fichier si vous devrez envoyer le
document j'en sais rien c'est là dessus
qu'on va vous juger c'est pas sur votre
présence au travail puisque sa personne
peut le voir donc c'est pour ça que dans
votre tout doux que vous faites la
veille
c'est important de dire ok mais
livrables à ce jour là ça doit être ça
genre la fin de la journée une journée
réussie
c'est une journée où j'ai envoyé ça ça
tel truc etc
c'est aussi une bonne opportunité pour
tous ceux qui travaillent beaucoup mais
qu on a l'impression de ne pas être
assez reconnue au sein de l'entreprise
plus présents parce que c'est vrai qu'on
est tous quelqu'un à qui brassent
beaucoup de vent et qui parlent beaucoup
on a l'impression qu'il fait mille trucs
qu'elle fait mille trucs est en fait en
fait non c'est juste que ça brasse du
vent
eh bien ces moments montré à tout le
monde que vous n'êtes pas cette personne
l'autre élément c'est évidemment de
parler avec des gens moi très souvent
j'ai des potes qui sont assez loin et
lui que je suis chez moi je suis tout
seul et que je déjeune tout seul je peux
c'est un peu triste de déjà et tout seul
moi j'aime pas trop il ya des gens qui
adorent ça mais bon c'est pas mon truc
eh ben je déjeune en faisant 1-1
scarabin une gargote un fêtard aime ce
que vous voulez soi ou duo soit vidéo ça
fait du bien quoi c'est juste le psy la
touche de sociabilité que qui manquent
parfois donc en ce moment j'avoue je
fais le midi et le soir très bonne
technique pour paître sont soit des
mesures du gouvernement toi c'est clair
enfin il imiter les distractions comme
vous avez un espace séparé dès
maintenant
l'idée c'est de mettre par exemple votre
téléphone ce genre de choses loin de cet
espace toi le plus loin possible pareil
mettait des bloqueurs d'application si
vous en avez bref utiliser ce genre de
choses pour vous en sortir
j'en parlerai plus tard dans une vidéo
où je pense qu'on va apprendre à mettre
quelques distances avec son smartphone
parce que l'addiction vos téléphones en
tout cas chez moi est un vrai problème
et j'imagine que ça peut intéresser
beaucoup d'entre vous voilà c'était une
toute petite vidéo qui me paraissait un
petit peu importante je me dis voilà ça
peut peut-être vous aider
j'espère que ça vous aidera si ça vous
aide si vous pensez que ça peut aider
d'autres membres de votre groupe
d'autres entreprises
n'hésitez pas à faire tourner mais voilà
j'espère que mon expérience va vous
aider là dedans et on se retrouve
dimanche pour une vidéo un petit peu
spécial ou enfin peu spécial plus
spécial qu'une autre on va pas se mentir
ou je veux vous apprendre à méditer
parce qu'en fait à partir de lundi matin
j'aurais bien faire un live de
méditation tous les matins comme ça
comment se tient la journée
voilà et en plus on essaie de se
détendre un peu plus de sérénité dans ce
climat qui est très difficile love peace
ciao et que je vous vois pas dans les
rues un petit coquin
jean prix pour juste donner un petit
conseil pour vous soulager le dos sur
une chaise on n'a pas de support
derrière alors que les chaises de gamer
par exemple sont faits pour rester
longtemps sans mardi il ya un petit
support donc ce que je vous conseille
cette fois un plaid genre une couverture
entre comme ça le cal est ici au plat et
là on est mieux
alors on avançait mieux legault je
trouve ça paraît bête mais vous assure
que quand on prend le temps de le faire
ça fait la diff